[Musique]
mes chers collègues
il faut savoir arrêter une réunion mais
il faut savoir la commencer aussi
Michel collègue ce directeur général
mais madame messieurs merci de votre
présence nous tenons aujourd'hui en fait
la première audition en réunion plénière
de notre mission d'information sur le
développement d'une filière de
biocarburant carburant de synthèse
durable et hydrogène vert créé à
l'initiative du groupe Union centriste
dans le cadre du droit tirage annuel
dont dispose les groupes politiques
cette réunion est captée et diffusée en
direct sur le site internet du Sénat
sur lequel elle pourra ensuite être
consulté en vidéo à la demande
monsieur le
j'indique d'ores et déjà à mes collègues
que demain à 17h30 à 17h
salle 263 c'est la seule des affaires de
la commission des Affaires économique
nous additionnerons en format rapporteur
le secrétaire général des affaires
européennes ce qui nous permettra
d'entrer dans le détail des négociations
en cours au niveau de l'Union européenne
vous êtes mes chers collègues bien
évidemment tout ce qu'on vit à cette
réunion notre prochaine réunion pliner
de mission d'information aura lieu le 28
février à 16h30 il s'agira d'une table
ronde consacrée aux différentes
technologies et aux efforts de recherche
qui réunira le Commissariat à l'énergie
atomique et aux énergies alternatives le
Centre national de la recherche
scientifique l'Agence nationale de la
recherche et l'IFP énergie nouvelle
aujourd'hui
pour cette première audition nous
recevons Monsieur Laurent Michel
directeur général de l'énergie et du
climat au ministère de la transition
écologique et de la cohésion des
territoires qui
occupent ces fonctions maintenant depuis
plus de 10 ans je salue également les
trois personnes qui l'accompagnent
monsieur Christophe cassiotis directeur
de cabinet monsieur Vincent Delporte
adjoint à la sous-direction en charge de
la sécurité d'approvisionnement et
nouveaux produits énergétiques et Madame
Victoire lantrain chargée de mission
merci de votre présence Monsieur le
Directeur général avec mes 22 collègues
membres de la mission
issus des différentes commissions du
Sénat sont donc de 7 et des
représentants l'ensemble des groupes
politiques du Sénat nous sommes
convaincus de l'enjeu que représente le
développement de ces filières
tant pour la capacité de la France et de
l'Union européenne à atteindre
l'objectif de neutralité climat
climatique à l'horizon 2050
que pour notre souveraineté et
compétitivité de notre économie les
travaux de notre commission
d'information sont pleinement ancrées
dans l'actualité la Commission
européenne vient en effet de publier un
acte délégué qui précise la notion
d'hydrogène vert après des négociations
tendues notre collègue Denis Saint-Pée
avait d'ailleurs interpellé la ministre
de la transition énergétique à ce sujet
la semaine dernière
j'observe également que ce matin même le
gouvernement a installé un groupe de
travail sur les carburants d'aviation
durable
je vous propose de nous dresser Monsieur
le Directeur général un panorama de la
filière de biocarburant de carburant de
synthèse durable et d'hydrogène vert
ainsi que les enjeux relatifs à leur
développement à partir du questionnaire
qui vous a été adressé par notre
rapporteur votre intervention luminaire
pourrait durer 10 à 15 minutes
je passerai ensuite la parole à notre
rapporteur Vincent capot canelas afin
qu'il puisse vous poser un certain
nombre de questions avant d'ouvrir le
débat à l'ensemble de mes collègues
cette audition ayant une dimension
transversale je souhaite j'espère
qu'elle sera longue et dense Monsieur le
Directeur je vous cède la parole
merci beaucoup monsieur le sénateur
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs merci
pour cette invitation à intervenir sur
ce sujet important de plus en plus vaste
puisque il y a 5 ans aussi on va
peut-être parler que de biocarburant et
moins de carburant de synthèse et on
aurait esquissé seulement l'hydrogène
alors qu'aujourd'hui tout ça a avance
donc juste pour prendre la direction
Christophe cassiotis directeur qui
lyonnaise aussi en charge tous les
sujets innovation et en particulier la
stratégie hydrogène donc en tant que de
besoin me soufflera ou vous deviendrez
en direct des éléments complémentaires
et la sous-direction de la sécurité
d'approvisionnement des nouveaux
produits énergétiques au travail Vincent
Delporte comme adjoint la sous
directrice et victoire lantrain en
charge tout ce qui est le secteur
pétrole et gaz mais avec le pétrole il y
a aussi tous les carburants liquides qui
donc dans les biocarburants et les
carburants de synthèse qui se
développent et aussi le biogaz vient
avec le gaz et sa direction aussi en
charge tout ce qui est le sous-sol dont
la géothermie mais ça nous intéresse
sera moins aujourd'hui alors peut-être
en introduction essayer un panorama qui
sera à la fois sûrement peut-être danse
mais aussi incomplet puisqu'on même en
15 minutes on peut pas tracer tout le
panorama mais en commençant par les
éléments généraux puis en commençant à
focaliser sur la question finalement
même s'il n'y a pas de certitude absolue
de quels sont les pistes
au regard des leviers de décarbonation
par usage et type de transport on l'a
beaucoup parlé transport et on verra que
tous les vecteurs énergétiques peuvent
avoir des rôles à jouer mais sont quand
même à ce jour plus ou moins adaptés
murs pour certains secteurs puis après
des des focus sur les biocarburants qui
eux sont déjà passablement plus anciens
et on a du recul les carburants de
synthèse à contrario nouveau et
l'hydrogène sur lequel on a une
stratégie nationale adoptée en 2020 qui
se développe alors sur les éléments
généraux
comme vous le savez
sans objectif complexes et
très engageant de réduire à la fois un
moyen terme de 2030 et bientôt peut-être
35 ans dans de nouvelles échéances de
55% niveau européen par rapport à 1990
nos émissions de gaz à effet de serre
puis la neutralité carbone qui a été
affirmée tant au niveau européen dans
les objectifs français il y a déjà
quelques années et donc ça adresse tous
les secteurs et y compris pas seulement
envers en vision verticale mais une un
ensemble de sujets transverses les les
transports sont sur quand on regarde au
plan national la première source
d'émissions de gaz à effet de serre de
30% des émissions domestiques et donc
c'est un un vecteur enfin secteur où il
est important d'agir depuis plusieurs
années les stratégies successives entre
de la stratégie nationale bas carbone et
la programmation plus annuelle de
l'énergie pour tous les secteurs
mettent en essaient de mettre développer
divers leviers d'abord la réduction des
consommations par sobriété ou efficacité
énergétique puis la décarbonation des
énergies utilisées avec en particulier
pour tous les secteurs mais aussi pour
les transports l'électrification mais
mais pas seulement alors pour réduire à
la fois vite et durablement les
émissions dans les transports on devra
optimiser un certain nombre de leviers
quasiment tous ceux qui sont plutôt sur
l'efficience générale des transports
optimiser l'utilisation des véhicules
qui soient de marchandises de transport
de marchandises ou de personnes le
report modal parce que certains modes
transports sont plus faciles à
décarboner que d'autres et dans la
décarbonation des énergies utilisées on
aura une certaine part d'électrification
mais pas seulement d'où l'intérêt de du
travail sur les des carburants on va
dire liquides ou gazeux complémentaires
à l'électricité c'est aussi pour pour
les transports et évidemment quelque
chose qui doit prendre en compte la
demande croissante de mobilité comment
peut-on à défaut de tout de suite la
fléchir au moins
grâce à peut-être plus d'efficacité dans
les transports
diminuer la hausse de cette mobilité
c'est aussi quelque chose qui évidemment
va marier comme tous les sujets
énergétiques et climatiques des
dimensions européennes des dimensions
nationales il s'agit d'implémenter
pardon de mettre en place les politiques
mais on a aussi des vrais marches de
manœuvre c'est aussi des développements
territoriaux ne sert à rien de dire du
National en mettons on fait un plan vélo
et puis qui se passe rien c'est
évidemment en lien avec le territoire
qui sont sources d'action et et d'idées
et ça sera aussi quelque chose de très
systémique en particulier les transports
l'organisation des transports leur
connexion mais aussi le lien
motorisation
infrastructures en particulier
davitaillement mais aussi infrastructure
de de la route elle-même
sont absolument à à mettre en synergie
alors si on va maintenant se focaliser
plus sur sur les usages en identifiant à
l'extrême on commence quand même à voir
se dessiner pour chacun des modes de
transport le transport routier léger
routier lourd les transports
ferroviaires l'aérien fluvial et
maritime un ensemble de contraintes et
de solutions qui fait que certaines
solutions
en termes d'énergie bas carbone sont
plus ou moins faciles à utiliser
clairement l'orientation prise et pas
qu'en France sur le transport léger
véhicule des particuliers et au moins
les utilitaires légers les moins gros
considère que avec les faibles émissions
du mix électrique français mais c'est
aussi le cas dans d'autres pays
européens comme la qui ont aussi des
mixes électriques très bas carbone et de
toute façon on y va ça incite à pousser
la mobilité et électrique comme solution
de de long terme si on compare à
l'hydrogène on estime que il y a assez
peu d'intérêt pour la mobilité légère du
moins la plus légère parce que
globalement la voie durable produire de
l'hydrogène ça va être à partir
d'électrolyse de l'eau mais vous avez un
rendement électrique d'électricité vers
hydrogène qui induit des pertes
d'énergie de 30 à 40% là où le rendement
du moteur est électrique et le plutôt
proche de de 100%. c'est l'orientation
de moyens long terme évidemment dans
cette mobilité légère le parc de
véhicules légers se renouvelle
progressivement et donc les
biocarburants qu'ils soient de première
génération ou avancée ont un rôle de de
transition non négligeable mais on va
vraiment on pense l'électrification
permet une importante réduction
l'émission de gaz à effet de serre y
compris en analyse de cycle de vie ça
implique aussi évidemment un effort
important sur les réseaux de recharge à
la fois dans les parkings privatifs qui
soient des résidences du résidentiel ou
des entreprises des collectivités et
autres organismes publics mais aussi sur
la voie publique
totalement accessible 85000 bornes au 31
janvier sont accessibles au public mais
dans ce qui est le plus le primevatif on
a dépassé un million de bornes
alors évidemment à ce stade malgré les
le début d'industrie de massification du
véhicule électrique certains noms de
mesures d'accompagnement restent
nécessaires comme les primes à
convention les bonus ainsi que
l'accompagnement de l'implantation de
l'infrastructure alors si vous allez sur
le véhicule routier plus lourd on voit
que pour le coup vous avez des le
véhicule est plus lourd transporte plus
de marchandises et peut être amené à
faire des plus longues distances et par
ailleurs c'est évidemment pour les
navires ou ou les avions
là vous voyez l'électrification ne va
pas être une solution immédiate voire de
long terme néanmoins tous les
déterminant technologiques et économique
ne sont pas figés
sur ce qui est de la mobilité routière
véhicule lourd vous voyez que le bus
électrique commence à être une solution
répandue quand vous allez au quart qui
donc voyage plus longuement et au poids
lourds l'offre est plus restreinte et
avec en particulier la question d'un
besoin d'autonomie important donc
induisant des poids de batterie
important néanmoins mais je n'en fais
pas quand ni une préférence ni une
prédiction on voit aujourd'hui un grand
nombre de constructeurs de poids lourds
considérant aussi qui ne peuvent pas
viser toutes les technologies qui
annoncent l'électrification de
l'ensemble de leur segment y compris les
poids lourds les plus gros porteurs on
voit aussi néanmoins que l'acide
solution gaz reste entre s'il y a du
biogaz
privilégié ou incluse par certains dans
leur gamme et par ailleurs certains
comptent proposer des poids lourds à
hydrogène alors par rapport plus léger
vous aurez toujours le rendement de
l'hydrogène de l'électricité vahydrogène
reste faible par contre vous avez une
capacité à emporter de manière assez
dense même si c'est moins dense que que
les les carburants classiques vous
pouvez vraiment porter une grande
quantité d'hydrogène vous le mettez dans
la suite vous avez votre pile à
combustible et avoir des autonomies
conséquentes pour les poids lourds à
hydrogène donc c'est une perspective
importante l'autre perspective restant
la décarbonation du carburants liquides
par un certain nombre de carburants de
biocarburant actuel ou futur alors pour
la mobilité aérienne et je crois que
vous l'avez évoqué les trois ministres
de chargé de l'énergie de l'industrie et
des transports à ce matin un groupe de
travail avec tous les acteurs les ceux
qui fabriquent les avions les
énergéticiens ils fabriquent les
carburants divers et les utilisateurs
compagnies aériennes et aéroport
pour le coup à ce jour l'électrification
n'apparaît pas tellement envisageable
même s'il y a des recherches ça
resterait probablement des petits avions
l'hydrogène est qualifiée sous contrôle
de Christophe de solution potentiel à
long terme pour des avions courts et
moyens courriers mais là il y a des
travaux de R&D mais c'est pas c'est
compliqué et donc au delà de on retrouve
finalement comme dans tous les secteurs
faire être plus efficace donc les avions
qui en base consomment moins parce
qu'ils sont plus légers parce qu'ils
sont plus aérodynamiques parce que aussi
les trajectoire sont optimisés mais
sauf rupture majeure le secteur et les
experts on l'a donc considéré que va
falloir que du carburant liquide des
carbonés
deviennent disponibles en volume
important pour réduire à court et long
terme les
les émissions donc biocarburant ou
éventuellement carburant de de synthèse
ça posera
une question à court terme on va dire de
la poulet de l'oeuf la demande commence
à émerger elle est en France
tirée par un dispositif d'incorporation
croissante enfin qui démarre qui démarre
comme on a pour le carburant routier
mais il va falloir que il y aura les
règlements européens qui vont y pousser
mais il va falloir que l'offre
industrielle
émerge et on l'espère sur le sol
européen et national et pas seulement
aller vers d'autres pays ou par ailleurs
peut-être la qualité en sens de impact
durable de ces carburants leur vraie
réduction d'émission de gaz à effet de
serre serait plus difficile à contrôler
donc une orientation de secteur au moins
dans une première mais longue phase vers
des biocarburants très durables ou des
carburants de synthèse à faible émission
avec néanmoins des projets de R&D en
particulier sur l'utilisation directe de
l'hydrogène pour les vols courts et
moyens courriers
pour les mobilités maritimes et
fluviales
un peu la même chose peut-être un tout
petit peu moins compliqué dans le sens
que vous pouvez avoir compris des
motorisations qui peuvent être
relativement flexibles
là vous avez pas les mêmes contraintes
très spécifiques des moteurs extrêmement
performants des avions donc vous pouvez
même imaginer des rétrophides de moteur
passant du carburant classique à
épouvant d'ores et déjà aujourd'hui
intégré des carburants avec une part
biologique mais y compris peut-être même
rétrophyte à l'hydrogène est aussi
utilisé pense on en parle beaucoup mais
on attend de voir les les prototypes et
les réalisations bien entendu
l'utilisation de l'hydrogène
hydrogène qui la combustible et on
avance
avec toutes les questions ça vaut pas
dans les navires mais dans c'est
important de sécurité puisque en plus le
navire pouvant lui-même transporter des
matières assez dangereuses les questions
seront importantes les certains
armateurs et professionnels du monde de
l'énergie de l'hydrogène étudier
également l'utilisation dérivée de
l'hydrogène comme le méthanol sur lequel
on reviendra ou aussi l'ammoniac comme
futur combustible donc là on serait plus
en pile à combustible on serait plutôt
en
moteur thermique bon les on va dire la
la nécessité en général le navire de
longue distance et de grosses quantités
énergies faites le moteur électrique
lui-même à ce jour resterait plutôt pour
la marine ou le fluvial quelque chose
pour l'instant de niche
l'électrification pour être par contre
évidemment importante pour des
carbonistes activités des ports et
aéroports comme par exemple tout ce qui
est quand les bateaux sont à terre ils
ont besoin d'électricité
plus intéressant de les pour
l'environnement de les raccorder plutôt
que de faire tourner les chaudières
diesel
alors sur les maintenant si j'aborde les
trois vecteurs que j'avais évoqué les
biocarburants au sens traditionnel que
l'on connaît donc des
liquides à part biologique utilisé dans
principalement aujourd'hui la propulsion
routière mais qui sont amenées à aller
vers les autres secteurs ce n'est pas
une histoire balbutiante c'est un déjà
un chemin qui a une certaine durée et
qui joue des rôles non négligeables
puisque globalement alors il y a
quelques subtilités de calcul
épidérations mais on est arrivé en
France aujourd'hui à une incorporation
de 8% des biocarburants dans les
essences et les gazols routiers
il y a un certain nombre
d'avantages et de facilités qui ont qui
maintenant sont adverbes on va dire que
un circuit logistique par exemple
moyennant qu'on fasse les mélanges dans
plutôt en âme parfois très en amont
parfois plutôt proche de la distribution
ça dépend de type de carburant mais
aujourd'hui on n'a pas besoin d'une
révolution de l'infrastructure on
distribue du diesel avec une part de
biocarburant en distribue de l'essence
avec une part on distribue le 85 quelque
chose qui roule alors aujourd'hui après
une phase qui est qui était qui avait
décidé un fort soutien tant par
défiscalisation qui tient aux
productions les moyens de soutien au
milieu carburant classique ce sont
simplifiés mais avec un levier qui reste
fort
le levier de l'obligation de
l'incorporation la la taxe que les
experts ont connu longtemps comme la
thyribbe qui maintenant la tire verte
taxe incitative qui donc en fait il y a
une obligation d'incorporation et si
vous la remplissez en tant que vendeur
de
vous ne payez pas la taxe dans le sens
qu'elle est appelée incitative
réussit-elle bien ou pas on peut dire
qu'en tout cas comme peu de gens la paie
on peut dire qu'en tout cas l'objectif
est atteint tout en étant légèrement
croissant et étant ayant été par
ailleurs ces dernières années on va dire
affiner avec des sous compartiments pour
pousser à l'incorporation d'un certain
nombre de biocarburant avancés
recyclant valorisant des déchets par
exemple cette cette incitation un peu
coercitive quand même faut le dire reste
nécessaire parce que le prix du
biocarburant est plus coûteux au niveau
de la molécule que l'équivalent fossile
il a et par ailleurs comme en
particulier
agricoles qui sont derrière des intrants
plus les coûts de transformation
si j'avais pris du pétrole monte
beaucoup ces prix-là via les un tout ça
monte aussi et par ailleurs quand les
prix du pétrole montent il y a
évidemment aussi de
la bataille on va dire pour s'assurer
son approvisionnement tant à la fois en
pétrole quand quand biocarburant il y a
plus donc avoir des tensions mais avant
même les tensions style guerre en
Ukraine là on va dire voilà c'est un
constat c'est pas une demande alors le
litre est plus cher à produire d'où le
besoin de de cette obligation
d'incorporation pour pérenniser cette
filière des carnation déjà largement
ancrée dans dans nos territoires ce les
élections des dernières années entre
autres avec la PPE de 2020 programmation
pluriel de l'énergie cette fixée des
objectifs d'un correction de
biocarburant dit deuxième génération qui
implique l'utilisation de matière qui
n'entre pas en concurrence avec la
production de produits alimentaires ça
c'est fait par ce sont des compétences
objectifs additionnelles à l'objectif de
de base
alors
même ça fait le l'objet de de débat qui
souvent sont vifs parieurs sur
intellectuellement et techniquement
complexes et évident que on doit viser à
ce que c'est biocarburant et un impact
global environnemental en émission de
gaz à effet de serre en analyse de cycle
de vie qui soit meilleur que le
carrément fossile en base ça peut être
assez simple mais au-delà c'est pas du
10% que que l'on vise c'est des 55 65 70
% ça dépend de l'âge de l'usine qui qui
transforme et c'est en généralise aussi
de vie en prenant en compte de plus en
plus la prise en compte des effets
directs dont la déforestation c'est pour
ça je pense vous souvenez de débats qui
ont été dans les PLF par exemple qui a
eu
en France décisions qui aujourd'hui
finalement vont pas rattrapés mais on
les suit par l'Union européenne de
bannir dans le comptage on les interdits
dans le comptage de biocarburant ceux
qui sont à base d'huile de palme et puis
progressivement mais la la pente de
réduction était forte de soja et les
directives européennes red de enfin la
nouvelle directive de 2018 en course fin
de transposition et l'arrêt 3 ainsi
règlement forest lutte contre la
déforestation importée on
remis tout cela dans un cadre européen
alors donc enfin je m'en arrête là c'est
de 40 classique mais il y a une en plein
de choses à dire on
répondra évidemment au questionnaire
puis il y aura les questions dans ce
traiterez dans l'audition j'avance sur
les les carburantes synthèse alors
qu'est-ce qu'on appelle
carburant de synthèse c'est l'idée de
recombiner
c'est ce qui est en train la définition
qui se cristallise et c'est là aussi les
au-delà la définition les efforts de R&D
se cristallise c'est la recombinaison
d'hydrogène et de carbone alors carbone
qu'on amène non pas à partir de
l'énergie fossile de base mais plutôt à
partir de monoxyde de carbone ou de
dioxyde de de carbone un désintérêt
évidemment ça c'est
quelque part d'économiser une fois le
carbone est mis si vous faites ça à
partir de CO2 que vous captez dans des
fumées de cimenterie à Syrie ou autre il
y a zéro émission mais vous avez quelque
part presque la moitié des émissions ça
dépend vous le comptez vous avez plus
l'émission de la cimenterie où vous avez
plus l'émission du carburant si votre
molécule est recyclé alors c'est quand
même quelque chose qui à la fois est
prometteur mais et nouveau dont on voit
que pour l'instant les rendements de
procédés de fabrication sont sont encore
faibles ça nécessite des quantités
importantes d'énergie entre autres
électriques entre autres pour produire
l'hydrogène associé évidemment les mêmes
questions de
qualification si vous voulez qu'il soit
qualifié de renouvelable faudra que
votre hétérogène lui-même soit alimenté
d'électricité renouvelable si vous
voulez qu'il soit de bas carbone il faut
avoir Kevin il faut avoir toute la
vision globale sur si vous faites votre
électricité à partir de gaz pour ensuite
faire de l'hydrogène il y a un problème
donc
l'importance que l'on a qu'on attache en
France à utiliser globalement
l'électricité de réseau des carbonées
pour produire de l'hydrogène des
carbones
donc j'ai dit à l'intérêt de capter et
de les mettre qu'une fois sur deux le
carbone ça peut permettre aussi si on
fait de chercher des procédés si vous
avez des procédés qui sont riches en CO2
pouvait directement le capter sans avoir
à épurer ce que vous captez c'est s'il
est comme dans tout l'anchimie c'est
quelque chose est très dense très riche
dans un produit vous avez moins de coûts
d'épuration c'est aussi un des choses
qui vont être de même en général le CO2
que vous captez il est d'origine fossile
si vous êtes enfin voilà oui il part
mais vous pouvez aussi imaginer que dans
on travaille les acteurs travaillent sur
du CO2 d'origine bioénique comme les
États nolwery ou certaines lignes de
biocarburants avancés vous pouvez voir
des filles de CO2 qui viennent de la
biomasse mais si vous voulez récupérer
là pour le coup c'est très très
intéressant alors qu'est-ce qu'on voit
émerger on voit entre autres les
carburants de synthèse de type méthanol
qui sont très regardées par le secteur
maritime un peu moins le secteur routier
parce qu'il y a peut-être d'autres
solutions ils sont intéressants côté
rendement parce que la combinaison de
carbone hydrogène c'est plus facile
méthanol molécule simple ou vous arrivez
à semble-t-il à avoir le meilleur
rendement pour la l'aviation qui elle
vise plutôt un carburant type kérosène
donc un carburant complexe là vous êtes
obligés d'aller sur des carburants de
synthèse plus complexes donc c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça tant sur les
biocavérante les carburantes synthèse
que le gouvernement avant même le
contrat d'aujourd'hui dans le cadre de
France 2030 a soutenu des des projets et
même avant dans le cadre du Pays-Bas
Pays-Bas a soutenu des projets dans le
cas de France de 30 il y avait une
enveloppe de 200 millions d'euros pour
soutenir des études et démonstrateurs
pour la production de carburants aériens
durable donc
carburant de synthèse avec quatre
projets bénéficiaires l'idée étant tant
sur les biocarbures avancé pour
laviation que pour les carburants de
synthèse pour l'aviation d'avoir d'ici
quelques mois quatre peut-être un
deuxième appel à projet pour soutenir
des phases d'industrialisation encore
plus fortes et à plus forte échelle de
ces carburants pour finir mon
introduction l'autre vecteur carburant
que vous avez dans votre champ donc
enfin c'est l'hydrogène qui d'ailleurs
n'est pas qu'un
envisager que comme carburant pour les
transports vous le savez la stratégie à
adopter en 2020 et qui est assez proche
de diverses stratégies dans pas d'autres
pays c'est comme il faut le produire
qu'on démarre c'est l'hydrogène que ce
n'est pas gratuit qui a des questions de
rendement il faut viser les
usages où il est le plus pertinent pour
la décarbonation d'abord l'industrie et
les mobilités intensives a besoin de
Fort énergie forte énergie dans dans un
premier temps l'industrie parce d'une
part on utilise aujourd'hui de l'énergie
fossile 900 notre hydrogène aujourd'hui
c'est à peu près 900000 tonnes de régime
fossile utilisée dans divers procédés
industriels mais 9 millions 9 millions
de tonnes de CO2 donc 2 et demi pour
cent et quel de nos émissions c'est cela
qu'il faut évidemment des décarbonés
avant d'inventer de nouveaux
usages de l'hydrogène on a déjà quelque
chose dès qu'on a de l'hydrogène durable
on y va mais c'est aussi donc j'y
reviens pas toutes ces il peut y avoir
aussi pardon des procédés industriels
nouveaux entre retransidérurgie ou
remplace des étapes utilisant du charbon
du Gazo pour la réduction des minerais
par des procédés utilisant en trône de
l'hydrogène et puis donc c'est cette
mobilité lourde
j'ai pas développé mais le train en
dehors le train évidemment est
électrique fiable mais là où il va pas
être électrifiée on retombe un peu sur
soit des diesels de synthèse soit aussi
l'hydrogène et vous savez qu'on soutient
des projets portés par Alstom et
cofinancer entre l'État et plusieurs
régions de démonstrateur et de premier
travail d'hydrogène pour l'endroit où on
ne pourrait pas l'utiliser par la seule
solution vous pouvez avoir aussi des
hybrides électriques qui roulent en
électrique et puis après charge des
batteries et qui finissent en électrique
quand ils sont sur la ligne non
électrifiée donc l'objectif donc c'est
plus d'hydrogène des carbonées nous
retenons à ce stade la
l'électrolyse de l'eau qui est un
procédé connu prometteur avec beaucoup
de recherches sur l'amélioration la mise
au point de nouveaux électrolyseurs à
plus haut plus haut rendement donc de
manière plus efficace économiquement
mais aussi énergétiquement puisque je
pense Jean-Christophe pour un de un
terrain water d'hydrogène faut quand
même aujourd'hui 1,7 d'électricité si on
peut améliorer les rendements ça moins
d'électricité à produire ce sera
bénéfique pour celui qui produira
l'hydrogène mais pour notre tout notre
notre système
donc
peut-être que enfin on ne ferme pas la
porte des procédés à partir de biomasse
pour ensuite passer en méthane et
ensuite en hydrogène mais capter le CO2
qui en viendrait ces procéder plus à
l'étude qui qu'on exclut pas mais qui
sont pas encore industrialisés
donc une base un usage industrie
usage mobilité lourde soutient à la
production mais aussi à toutes les
technologies donc évidemment les
technologies développement des
technologies d'électrolyse l'été la
production mais aussi les technologies
d'utilisation la pile à combustible n'a
pas encore où tous les erreurs et tout
ça n'a pas encore l'historique de
perfectionnement même si on est loin de
la préhistoire mais on peut encore
beaucoup avancer sur ces sujets donc le
les plans gouvernementaux de depuis 2020
soutiennent des phases de R&D et
démonstrateurs soit pour
valider les nouveaux modèles des
extrusur et ensuite faire les grandes
usines production d'électrolyse des il y
a des projets sur la pile à combustible
là aussi mise au point et
usine et aussi des premiers projets de
production massive d'hydrogène on vise
en termes de production 6,5 gigawh
d'électrolyse installé en 2030 la
version actuelle de la
stratégie on devrait quand même avoir
assez vite ou contre ils savent plus de
2 gigawatts soutenus par l'ensemble des
appels à projets qui dans certains ont
déjà été sélectionnés on a un projet qui
sont co-financés entre la France et le
urbaine dans le cadre des projets
d'intérêt commun dont des projets de
production
d'hydrogène on a d'ailleurs aussi
trouver
travailler sur divers mécanismes de
soutien dont au moins un court moyen
terme qui durera un certain temps tant
que les technologies d'électrolyse
n'auront pas atteint le prix du de
l'hydrogène fossile des soutiens à la
production un peu comme pour les
renouvelables biogaz ou électricité un
soutien par rappel d'offres en retenant
les projets qui présentent le meilleur
rapport qualité prix mais où on
compenserait la le coût de production
versus le prix nécessaire et acceptable
pour qu'il se se développe cela
fait l'objet d'un mécanisme qui a été
notifié à la Commission européenne avec
qui on a déjà eu nombreux échanges et on
espère l'approbation cette année pour
pouvoir lancer les appels à projet et
puis on soutient aussi le développement
d'un certain nombre d'écosystèmes
territoriaux au-delà des grands
démonstrateurs donc combinaison de
production et d'utilisation locale dans
l'industrie et la mobilité lourde sont
des des premiers ces stratégies sont
évolué le président de la République a
demandé qu'on la revoit cette année au
vu on va dire la demande croissante
d'hydrogène entre autres dans
l'industrie dans les stratégie de
décarbonation il y aura des questions à
se poser par exemple sur
l'infrastructure hydrogène en France et
en Europe bassin locaux avec plutôt
consommation proche de la production
mais aussi des gros lieux de production
reliés à des lieux de consommation par
un réseau qui développerait
progressivement donc ça c'est question à
traiter la prochainepe quel réseau
d'infrastructures quel modèle économique
est-ce qu'on profite à des réseaux
réguliers
tels les modèles de gaz électricité ou
est-ce qu'il y a un élan de réseau
régulier et de réseau d'initiative privé
au moins sur les petits réseaux il y
aura aussi des questions d'importation à
la fois au niveau européen et national
les ambitions européennes entre des
programmes ripower ou autre parle de 20
millions de tonnes à horizon 2030
consommer en Europe ce qui dont pas sûr
que le calcul a été fait de manière
précise mais donne des ordres de
grandeur un potentiel fabriqué en Europe
de 10 millions de tonnes et des
importations d'inondon on aurait
tendance en France à penser qu'il y a
peut-être à d'abord faire émerger notre
production mais ça veut dire aussi que
il faut être réaliste que on aura
peut-être besoin de ces importations ce
qui est en train de se dessiner il y a
eu pas mal de commentaires récemment sur
différents projets de règlement européen
c'est un centre de choses de convergent
pas sur les pas encore signifiant
d'hydrogène renouvelable bas carbone et
alors là ce qui converge assez bien
c'est que l'hydrogène importé pour être
qualifié de bas carbone il devra avoir
les mêmes performances et une capacité à
suivre cette performance en termes des
missions de CO2 par rapport au kilo
d'hydrogène c'est aussi qu'on partage
avec un temps de pays c'est que cet
approvisionnement européen devra être
notion de qualité et durable mais aussi
on va dire encadrer et et diversifier
pour éviter de retomber dans des
dépendances excessives qu'on pourrait
avoir vis-à-vis d'un seul producteur
d'hydrogène comme on a eu vis-à-vis d'un
seul producteur de gaz naturel donc un
certain nombre de sujets qui vont scaler
dans les années à venir pour l'hydrogène
et puis à terme peut-être d'autres
usages aussi là comme moyen de stockage
de l'électricité
voilà je sais pas si j'ai sûrement duré
plus que le quart d'heure mais c'est pas
me permettre le sujet est large
je suis pas sûr de l'avoir néanmoins
épuisé les questions merci Monsieur
Laurent Michel pour cette introduction
sur un sujet effectivement large et je
vais passer la parole à notre rapporteur
merci monsieur le Président c'est le
directeur général merci d'avoir de ce
vaste panorama foisonnant que vous nous
avez délivré je vais presque envie de
vous dire en introduction n'y voyez pas
une provocation mais que c'est un peu à
l'image de de la stratégie de
décarbonation c'est à dire qu'on a le
sentiment qu'on s'est fixé beaucoup
d'objectifs et que évidemment on peine à
délivrer alors c'est normal me
direz-vous à ce stade là mais on va
arriver au stade de la révision de la
stratégie française énergique climat et
donc vous avez dit beaucoup de choses ce
que je voudrais bien comprendre c'est
aujourd'hui
qu'elle je vais pas dire qu'elle trie
mais si vous devez tamiser un peu ces
objectifs vous devez les hiérarchiser si
vous devez nous dire en quoi on a
progressé
voilà j'aimerais un peu mieux vous
entendre sur c'est quoi les grands axes
et qu'elles sont les difficultés que
vous rencontrez aujourd'hui notamment
comprendre mieux quand même
l'évolution la stratégie avec alors on
aura une audition demain mais quand même
d'ores et déjà quel est l'évolution des
discussions européennes et en quoi ça
influe la stratégie française mais aussi
sur la définition d'un certain nombre de
choses vous avez abordé le carburant
carburant synthétique hydrogène vert ou
est-ce qu'on en est dans la définition
de tout ça parce qu'il y a des enjeux de
stratégie il y a des enjeux
scientifiques qu'on veut aborder il y a
aussi des discussions européennes qui
doivent nous servir à encadrer un peu un
peu les choses au fur et à mesure mais
voilà quel est votre évolution de la
stratégie qui va être évaluation et
l'évolution de la stratégie
votre appréciation sur les solutions de
décarbonation aussi ce que vous avez
cité pas mal c'est très bien mais
qu'est-ce qui vous paraît pouvoir se
décliner en filière française est-ce
qu'on a des risques pour pouvoir faire
que ce soit des filières souveraines
parce que c'est pas tout d'avoir une
réflexion sur la spécifique sur l'aspect
industriel mais est-ce qu'on est capable
d'ailleurs de délivrer ou est-ce qu'on
va passer d'une dépendance à l'autre là
dessus
je les conflits d'usage vous avez abordé
très justement d'ailleurs très
honnêtement le fait que
de mettre très transport en pardon le
fait qu'il y avait aussi des situations
où on pouvait discuter vous nous avez
beaucoup parlé de l'aérien en nous
disant que là c'était plutôt
effectivement des carburants
synthétiques avec des caractéristiques
particulières d'ailleurs mais que ça
pouvait être pour d'autres modes de
transport l'idée vous n'avez pas
beaucoup parlé de l'industrie aussi mais
est-ce qu'il y a des concurrences je
pense à l'hydrogène notamment et des
besoins pas uniquement pas uniquement en
matière de transport mais sur
sur
l'industrie et puis enfin quel est le
type de soutien est-ce que c'est trop
tôt pour dire aujourd'hui quand on
reprend tout ça on essayait en
hiérarchiser les l'état scientifique le
processus européen l'appréciation que
nous avons de l'atteindre des objectifs
et les conflits d'usage est-ce qu'on est
capable aujourd'hui de se reposer la
question des mesures de soutien
c'est une toute petite question
c'est alors
dans qu'est-ce qui marche qu'est-ce qui
progresse qu'est-ce que l'on peut faire
on a évidemment tout dépend de la focale
est-ce qu'on est très globale sur
ensemble de décarbonation et par moments
on doit l'être parce que tout est lié
vous avez parlé conflit d'usage il
reviendrai sur la biomasse vous pouvez
pas faire vous mais c'est à VOUS
collectif nous ne pouvons pas faire
semblant de croire qu'on a tellement de
biomasse qu'on va chauffer tous les
logements au biogaz et remplir tous les
camions de biocarburant et tous les
avions etc un moment ça ça ne colle pas
donc il y a des moments où tout doit on
doit avoir des visions intégrées mais
les moments il faut effectivement se
pencher sur la la globalité
mais aussi un moment regardé secteur par
secteur quels sont justement les
impasses autres alors si on regarde en
global sur la vision strat bas carbone
PPE
ce qui doit mieux mieux marcher c'est
encore de c'est l'efficacité énergétique
dans tous les secteurs on n'est pas que
soit en rénovation en industrie en
transport ont des livres pas
extraordinairesment la preuve à
contrario qui est une bonne preuve même
si on aurait souhaité le faire avant
c'est que le signaux prix ou la peur de
manquer si vous passez cette expression
au moment de la crise Russo ukrainienne
a déclenché beaucoup d'économies
d'énergie dont certaines sont subies
mais aussi beaucoup d'actions dont on se
rend compte qu'elles sont simples ou
certaines rentabilité et ça c'est c'est
vrai pour tous les secteurs ceux qui est
un peu au cœur entre des orientations
qui ont été posées par le Président de
la République et le gouvernement c'est
donc d'une part ce gros effort à faire
sur l'efficacité énergétique globalement
la maîtrise des consommations et ensuite
essayer d'avoir les vecteurs des
carbonées là où il faut
c'est et donc c'est un peu du beaucoup
de choses à la fois c'est sur le
logement en particulier beaucoup de
chaleur renouvelables de la biomasse et
utiliser efficacement dans des
chaudières bois collectives ou autre de
la géothermie ça peut être du gaz etc
c'est c'est aussi utiliser le potentiel
biomasse et là il y a il y aura des
débats d'un site à l'autre par ailleurs
vous pouvez avec l'évolution des
technologies avec certaines ressources
faire du liquide du gaz et ou de la
chaleur tout n'est pas fongible mais ça
peut l'être c'est donc d'utiliser ce
potentiel mais de manière durable sans
faire baisser nos surfaces forestières
nos surfaces agricoles sans se lancer
dans une course en avant à la culture
dédiée et puis c'est l'électrification
plus forte de l'économie parce que y
compris pour le chauffage avec des modes
de chauffage donc pompe à chaleur
efficace vous pouvez chauffer plus avec
un plus et mieux et ça c'est des
vecteurs assez quand on a sûr de
remplacement des fossiles une partie des
transports s'éclaire peut s'électrifier
vous avez vu lesquels plutôt les léger
plutôt que les lourds même s'il y a des
débats et l'industrie l'industrie peut
bénéfier d'une électeur d'une
électrification directe ou indirecte
direct changer des procédés la
sidérurgie est pas qu'au niveau français
ni au mondiale c'est l'ormittal il pense
au même procédé partout dans dans le
monde va passer en réduction directe du
fer plus plutôt que d'utiliser des
procédés à base de d'agglomération
minerais très émetteur donc il y a de
l'électrification directe et puis
parfois aider par l'hydrogène donc vous
en pouvez remplacer certains vecteurs de
chaleur par de l'hydrogène et là c'est
une électrocution je qualifie indirecte
vu qu'on considère qu'on fait
l'hydrogène à partir d'électricité donc
ça veut dire que même si on arrive à
diminuer des consommations d'électricité
sur certains vecteurs on l'a vu dans la
crise moins 8 moins 10% on sait faire
des choses
certification va amener plus de de
consommation donc ça c'est c'est la
vision un peu d'hélicoptère mais qui
après trouve à s'articuler de manière
différente dans chaque on voit sur les
les transports oui on voit bien qu'il
n'est pas simple même si à certains
succès comme le plan vélo et on espère
la relance du covoiturage il est pas
très simple je dis pas que c'est un
grand succès ni un empêché mais n'est
pas très simple mais c'est un de lever
sur lequel si on veut être efficace à
court terme il faut beaucoup aller le
rappeur modal au sens large il va pas
tout faire tout le monde ne sera pas à
vélo et toutes les marchandises ne sont
pas sur des trains ou sur des péniches
partout on va pas tout changer c'est
difficile il y a des succès il y a des
échecs c'est c'est un des axes sur
lesquels il faut travailler donc de la
route vers le faire pour les
marchandises
un peu les mobilités actives au moins
métropole ou même enfin vélo ça c'est
pas on peut pas on peut faire plus que 3
km s'il y a des incitations des
aménagements etc donc ça c'est un des
axes de progrès après on voit bien sur
les transports qu'il y a vraiment besoin
de travailler sur les efficacité de la
chose qui bouge qui est la chose plus
son moteur c'est comment ça vient de
plus en plus efficace à ce que même si
on arrive on avait et c'est pas simple
parce que ça consomme de la biomasse ou
de l'hydrogène l'électricité beaucoup de
biocarburant vraiment c'est compliqué
d'en faire donc moi ils en consommeront
est-ce que je disais les avionneurs ce
matin à La Réunion président
et le pense atteignable par rapport aux
avions les plus performants vendus
aujourd'hui les A320 néo par exemple
c'est de faire -40%. donc il faut quoi
qu'il en soit être très efficace
surtout ses vidéos mais après il faut
des carbonner et donc là je vous
c'est c'est plus ou moins efficace mais
je pense qu'on enfin les vecteurs sont
plus ou moins adaptés je pense qu'on
voit se dessiner plutôt hydrogène et
certains carburants de synthèse pour les
mobilités lourdes avec des variations
entre le train et l'avion c'est lourd
mais c'est plus compliqué de faire
l'hydrogène dans l'avion alors que le
train ça peut l'être et l'électrique
fait on dirait c'est et plutôt de
l'électrification pour les mobilités
légères et puis des paris technologiques
et industriels autour du poids lourd ou
là la balance ou avantage et facilité de
progresser
c'est difficile de dire que est-ce que
le camion hydrogène va devenir
finalement pas très cher et très
performant alors qu'aujourd'hui les
constructeurs se lancent et par les
constructeurs étant moins nombreux et
veillant de marcher moins gros que le
véhicule léger ils vont pas tirer toutes
les pistes tout azimuts même pour ces
voitures légères on voit bien les
constructeurs
se focalisent
donc ça globalement c'est vraiment un
enjeu de l'amélioration de l'efficacité
du véhicule et un enjeu de produire ces
vecteurs et là
c'est on a des équations qui peuvent
apparaître mais qui sont qui vont être
un peu aussi du Sarr mais on sent qu'il
faut là quand même sur un certain nombre
de ces nouveaux camions il faut soutenir
l'offre clairement par
un mélange c'est pour ça les de
d'obliger quelque part les mandats
d'incorporation qui sont aujourd'hui
dans la législation française qui vont
arriver par les gestion européenne elle
crée de l'offre en obligeant les
avionneurs par les avions les compagnies
aériennes à en utiliser mais ça ne sera
pas suffisant il faut clairement que
dans la phase d'industrie enfin
d'innovation puis d'industrialisation on
aide la création du d'usine de soins
vous évoqué aussi entre autres par
rapport à l'Amérique et son inflation en
réduction Act
c'est pas des marchés totalement
mondiaux mais c'est pas non plus des
marchés totalement de proximité il faut
que un certain que sans même parler de
la souveraineté mais si vous avez
beaucoup si un moment un grand continent
va beaucoup plus vite que les autres sur
la production de ces nouveaux carburants
les autres les front moins cher enfin
plus cher et plus lentement et puis ça
serait quand même assez embêtant
effectivement que les carburants
durables les avions ou les bateaux ne
puissent s'approvisionner que sur le sol
de certains pays donc il y a vraiment un
enjeu d'accélérer c'est un
industrialisation sur semaine à la
question de les que vous évoquiez des
des soutiens
on a la conviction dans nos équipes et
au-delà que on doit vraiment avoir tout
en étant réactif sur un moment qu'est-ce
qu'on arrête qu'est-ce qu'on débranche
la combinaison soutient à l'innovation
donc
cette longue haleine les acteurs dont
l'IFPEN ont cité des projets qui
s'appelait beautiful ou autre ou futural
qui ont de travaux des organismes de
recherche d'entreprise pour développer
justement ces 45s des choses qu'on
mettait du pays vers 2014 2015 c'est
vieux aujourd'hui on commence à avoir
les à se dire qu'il y a les premières du
trail faut soutenir cette phase
d'innovation mais aussi cette phase
d'industrialisation de même que pour
pour être performant au plan
environnemental mais aussi la
souveraineté il faut qu'on ait un
certain nombre d'usine de batterie en
Europe et on va de soutenir juste la R&D
ne suffit pas il faut c'est la
conviction qui je crois se répand aussi
en Europe il y a un moment dans cette
montée en puissance il faut un soutien à
l'investissement industriel et dans
certains cas la combinaison d'une
réglementation qui oblige à consommer et
de vrais sanctions quelque part la taxe
que personne ne paye c'est une sanction
pour ceux qui refuseraient d'incorporer
ou qui a des biocarburants
restera nécessaire sur les conflits
d'usage enfin sur l'hydrogène ça me
faisait
on pense qu'il faut aller là où c'est
efficace
[Musique]
électricité là-bas s'il y a plus de
besoins ça sera batterie ou hydrogène
mais moi donc ça le conflit d'usage on
va dire il est là d'où l'enjeu c'est
finalement c'est pas un conflit sur une
ressource finisse et une ressource
sacrée qui nécessite qu'on soit capable
de produire assez d'électricité
dans le court moyen long terme dans des
conditions de durabilité le choix c'est
un mix à base de nucléaire et de
renouvelable et d'avoir des
électrolyseurs performants parce que on
pense qu'il y a encore des des capacités
d'amélioration des rendements
pour la biomasse là c'est un sacré c'est
un sacré sujet parce que
la biomasse elle a des facteurs
limitants qui sont notre surface qui
sont la volonté de ne pas être en
concurrence avec les usages alimentaires
d'avoir une biomasse et on n'est pas
compte il y a un certain nombre de
possibilités de culture intermédiaire
qui vont dans les métazotes ça c'est
encadré en même temps faut que ces
cultures dites intermédiaires il faut
qu'elle même elle soit durable si on est
obligé de mettre plein d'engrais et un
moment faut un peu désengrais mais plein
d'engrais plein d'eau et tout pour
produire un certain nombre de
plantes pas très performantes pour faire
du méthane votre méthane il a un bilan
pas terrible d'où la focalisation du
biométhane sur les d'abord les déchets
un peu de culture dédié un peu de
culture intermédiaire donc limitation
notre surface les objectifs qu'on se met
de pas la
et puis
tout n'est pas interchangeable c'est il
y a des idées qu'à partir du bois on
puisse par maintenant avec perroquet
efficaciation faire du méthane mais à ce
moment si vous mettez tout le bois là
dedans vous aurez peut-être plus de
biogaz mais moins ces déchets de bois il
s'agit de mettre des déchets de bois
dans les chaudières s'agit pas de mettre
des gros troncs c'est pas ça le
l'objectif donc il y a un moment les
interchangeabilités quand même vous
peuvent vous déstabiliser un certain
nombre de filières y compris même si on
pense que le biocarburant pour avancer
pour l'aviation est une des solutions va
falloir vérifier que les bilans biomasse
et énergie font font pas que à court
moyen terme on tire de la biomasse y
compris à un moment si on faisait pas
attention que tu as dû inviter on
enlèverait du bois pour faire du bois
d'oeuvre donc le bilan biomasse et et
quelque chose de compliqué qu'on va
essayer d'éclairer mais au-delà de
l'éclairer dans les stratégies il va
falloir le suivre même si sur un certain
nombre de sujets que soient les
biocarburants ou le biogaz on a encore
des potentiels de déchets à valoriser
qui sont négligeable en même temps on
fait pas exprès de jeter des déchets il
y en a d’abord dans la politique de
gestion des chambres on essaye d'en
produire moins du style lutte contre le
gaspillage alimentaire quand il y a des
chas alimentaires on peut en faire des
choses il s'agit pas de faire exprès des
déchets pour faire du biogaz c'est
une des rares certitudes que je puisse
avoir entre autres celle-là sur les
définitions
sous contrôle de Christophe et Vincent
les définitions européennes sont plutôt
en train de converger sur les
biocarburants les biocarbures même
l'hydrogène bas carbone et renouvelable
là où on a un débat entre autres sur
l'hydrogène c'est que
même si je vais le faire je vais essayer
de le faire tel que moi je le comprends
c'est pas le plus grand expert pour être
compléter c'est que et en ayant
absolument rien contre une capacité de
faire de l'hydrogène d'y renouvelable on
estime que dans l'état actuel de notre
mix de la
pas besoin d'électricité supplémentaire
et de du fait qu'il est décarboné qu'on
peut essayer à court terme de remonter
par le park résistant notre production
de nucléaire de et qui peut être utile
de pouvoir donner une large place à
l'hydrogène des carbonée qui finalement
certains le dishydrogène nucléaires non
c'est juste un hydrogène utilisant de
l'électricité du réseau avec toutes les
traçabilités qui vont bien en
particulier de vérifier que façon bilan
carbone c'est-à-dire que finalement il
faut pas il faut aussi compter quand on
est en pic et que là c'est centrale à
gaz qui tourne faut le compter dans le
bilan carbone mais on sait faire ça et
donc on pense que c'est là quelque chose
qui serait contre-productif que par des
objectifs trop rigides finalement on
passe en face tout notre on court à
atteindre de l'hydrogène renouvelable en
se privant de l'autre hydrogène plus
générale mais on n'a rien compris donc
plus qu'une question de définition des
molécules enfin des elle-même c'est la
manière d'avoir des objectifs
qui laisse un peu de suzidarité à
contrario un pays qui a pas de nucléaire
et qui développe de plus en plus
d'électricité renouvelables la France
l'empêchera pas de faire son son
hydrogène renouvelable et par ailleurs
il y aura en France aussi de l'hydrogène
en bleu c'est cette équilibre qui qu'on
essaie de trouver dans des débats donc
on dirait je les les retransmissions
médiatiques sont parfois un peu
raccourcis c'est normal
je sais pas attends Christophe avait
noté tous les
j'avais oui alors après enfin peut-être
bon vous avez posé des questions de
hiérarchisation souveraineté enfin bon
la hiérarchisation effectivement c'est
essayer de trouver des règles simples
mais vrai et éventuellement qu'on change
si on voit les technologies si on voit
des choses géniales tel usage
d'hydrogène qu'on n'a pas prévu faut pas
qu'on reste coincé sur notre stratégie
mais donc des défis instants des
hiérarchisation quels sont les vecteurs
énergétiques
les plus utiles et qu'elles sont ceux
qui sont aussi sans regret et ça peut
varier dans le temps on ne sait pas
combien de gaz gazeux on utilisera dans
en 2050 c'est juste qu'il sera
totalement décarboné et comment le
produira c'est compliqué aujourd'hui à
contrario une décision sans regret si on
produit du biogaz durable ça va être peu
de culture dédiée et compagnie c'est
sans regret parce que on a tellement de
gaz fossiles à décarboner sur les 15 ans
qui viennent ce biogaz n'est pas perdu
idem pour le les biocarburants euh
classique qu'on s'est produire et à
pendant encore longtemps suffisamment de
véhicules thermiques pour qu'on se pose
pas tout de suite la question c'est
enfin on n'a pas besoin d'arrêter les
bio carburants d'aujourd'hui pour ne
faire que les biocarburants de demain
c'est c'est un peu des des ce que
l'appel des décisions sans regret en
néant moins qu'il est aussi sans regret
de de développer ces nouvelles
technologies et de la manière la plus
efficace pour ce qui est de de filière
française le panorama pour être long et
et vaste bon et ayant tête évidemment
que par ailleurs enfin quand on est sur
les fossiles disons régulièrement à part
maîtriser des technologies de
transformation de rafinal ça ou et
d'avoir des groupes qui se projettent à
l'international en ingénieur ou c'est
vrai on a un vrai savoir-faire français
pour le coup vous savez toujours on ne
maîtrise rien toutes les molécules
fossiles ou quasiment sont sont importés
et toute la valeur ajoutée elle est
ailleurs sur les filières plutôt on va
dire de de biomasse
on a une certaine expérience
industrielle on sait fabriquer du
biodiaisel du bioéthanol de première
génération et on commence à développer
des procédés de deuxième génération
on a mais en même temps je dis pas qu'il
faille être en autarcie ayant aussi
conscience que selon les années sont
aussi les équilibres etc on importe
aussi des biocarburants ou une partie
des matières premières qu'on met dans
nos usines en soi c'est pas c'est pas un
drame mais voilà il faut bien avoir en
tête que on ne peut pas forcément être
totalement au tout suffisant surtout
l'objectif est étant qu'on est au niveau
français et européen c'est ça qui a des
projets communs autant l'ipcei
effectivement si on développe de
l'hydrogène et on y croit sincèrement
moi j'y crois sur la on est capable en
Europe mais il y a pas 15 ans à attendre
d'avoir des générations d'électrolyseurs
performants et on pourrait avoir des
usines de de production bon si on attend
5 10 ans il viendront de Chine ou des
États-Unis
voilà et on en aura sûrement aussi qui
viendront chez les États-Unis on en
exportera aussi
et parieurs déjà français c'est
exportent en Allemagne faut jamais
oublier sur l'hydrogène enfin un peu
toute l'utilisation les piles à
combustibles on a c'est un bio qui est
très pointu on a toute la question des
réservoirs c'est c'est voilà c'est
l'intégration aussi c'est un train
hydrogène c'est pas tout à fait un train
à diesel quoi c'est
sur pareil sur les filières de
biocarburant ou de carburant synthétique
on n'est pas ni les derniers ni les
premiers à être sur le sujet il y a des
ce sont des technologies il y a des
technologies étrangères où il y a les
nôtres s'agit aussi évidemment une
certaine maîtrise au niveau national de
première industrialisation permettrait
aussi de vendre l'ingénierie d'où l'idée
qu'on soutiennent aussi les premières
industrialisations
après il y a beaucoup de Cédric pour
être quelque part portés par les
entreprises un peu multinationales au
sens qu'elles sont présentes en France
en Allemagne et en Finlande
certains
si on a quelques technologies que l'on
maîtrise sur l'électrolyseur si jamais
un jour un pays
avec 90% du marché décidaient de nous
couper les ventes des trésors on serait
très embêtés mais si on est à capacité
d'en faire un petit peu à ce moment-là
on a un peu une dissuasion entre
guillemets c'est une question qu'on peut
se poser aussi sur les panneaux solaires
pour le l'Europe ou les États-Unis vont
faire plus vont utiliser plus de
panneaux solaires on n'aura jamais 100%
de nos panneaux solaires pour produire
en Europe dans les 5 ans qui viennent
faut il y a une grande industrie
chinoise qui en fait est très
performants et pas cher avoir une
capacité en Europe à fournir ce qu'on va
consommer en plus au moins une partie
serait un gage de de souveraineté et
d'alternative
de la qualité de vos réponses j'ai les
collègues qui souhaitent poser les
questions monsieur dumilly
moi je souhaite intervenir sur le
biocarburant de première génération
j'ai présidé le lancer le groupe
d'études sur les biocarburant à
l'Assemblée nationale il y a plus de 20
ans à l'époque on l'a fait contre la vie
des pétroliers on l'a fait aussi contre
la vie des ministères et on a réussi à
développer la filière par le biais du
calendrier d'incorporation par le biais
de la défiscalisation et aujourd'hui on
a la chance d'avoir effectivement une
une filière qui qui tourne bien et tout
particulièrement celle de l'éthanol que
vous connaissez puisque vous avez
parcouru les champs de betterave quand
vous étiez probablement de rire du
Pas-de-Calais mais il y a déjà il y a
déjà un certain temps et je voudrais
vous poser une question sur ce sujet là
d'abord une première question sur le sur
le court terme puisque vous savez que
que l'actualité nous amène à
à parler des néonicotinoïdes et la fin
de l'interdiction de de cet endroit
enrobage de semences fait que
aujourd'hui le monde agricole veut se
détourner de la production betteravière
et donc on risque d'avoir finalement de
tuer dans l’œuf une filière qui était
naissante avec celle de l'éthanol
tout à l'heure vous disiez que c'était 8
% d'incorporation en moyenne le 10 et le
plus vendu en France aujourd'hui le 85
se développe de partout et dont je
voulais savoir quel était votre
sentiment par rapport à cette décision
donc européenne que nous allons devoir
malheureusement appliquer ici en France
et quels seront les répercussions sur la
filière éthanol en France ça c'est la
question court terme et la question
moyen terme que je voulais voir avec
vous et celle bien sûr de la fin des
moteurs thermiques qui est programmé et
donc indirectement de la fin de
l'incorporation de de biocarburant donc
dans les dans les carburants classiques
là aussi quel est votre regard qu'elle
regarde vous portez sur sur cette
situation et sur ce sur ce sur cette
évolution économique et sociale qui va
donc nous attendre dans quelques années
il y a deux autres collègues qui
souhaitent et puis voilà parce que
Monsieur Salomon
monsieur le Président juste deux petites
questions j'aurais revenir sur les
biocarburants pourriez-vous nous dire à
l'heure actuelle quels sont les surfaces
occupées en France par ces biocarburants
et les analyses le cycle de vie
qu'est-ce que ça donne exactement parce
qu'il y a beaucoup de controverses là
dessus aussi sur le bio Diesel sur le
bioéthanol quels sont les analyses les
dernières en date et les plus crédibles
merci
[Musique]
Président vous avez évoqué sur les
bio-carburants Monsieur le Directeur le
fait que les compagnies pétrolières ne
payaient pas
la TGAP la terrible c'est normal si la
paille pas ça veut dire qu'ils
incorporent on est bien d'accord non
mais je crois qu'il faut bien le dire
dans ce sens là
sur
le
les facteurs limitants
pour l'ensemble des énergies
renouvelables de toutes les générations
je veux dire aujourd'hui on s'aperçoit
que
certes on a démarré avec une production
de biocarburant à partir de biomasse
produite je voudrais quand même rappelé
notre commission que il n'y a pas plus
d'un an pour produire des énergies que
de produire de l'alimentation on est
bien d'accord sur le plagonomique
tout à l'heure qu'il fallait plus d'un
train pour produire des énergies
dites biocarburantes
la matière première que l'on produire
enfin la matière végétale la biomasse
qu'elle soit à destination alimentaire
ou une alimentaire elle a les mêmes
conditions de production de les mêmes
moyens qui sont mis on en met pas plus
d'un an pour produire de l'énergie que
de produire pour des betteraves ou du
colza ou du tournesol ou du maïs ou du
blé
de production
à caractère alimentaire ou non
alimentaire c'est les mêmes moyens les
mêmes besoins pour la plante voilà
c'est ce que j'ai compris un petit peu
dans votre voilà et je révolution
pouvait avoir ou si vous aviez imaginé à
des GEC un tableau qui dit ce qu'il
mette bien en parallèle toutes les
énergies d'aujourd'hui biocarburant
première génération et ensuite toutes
les autres énergies de synthèse ou
d'hydrogène et de voir quel était les
volumes que à laquelle on pouvait
prétendre atteindre avec les matières
premières qui étaient les nôtres dans
chaque production à quel terme et à quel
prix et à quel retour environnemental
possible
[Musique]
beaucoup de questions dans certaines
sont connectés j'essayais de répondre à
à tous sans même sans me prêter à l'art
d'esquiver la question qui à laquelle
j'ai pas la réponse
alors sur mon la première sur la la
question de la betterave enfin la
version de betterave l'interruption des
semences je suis pas spécialiste du
sueur la presse et voilà effectivement
va se poser
des questions est-ce qu'on trouve des
alternatives et comment et qu'elle va
être l'impact sur la fonction de
betterave et donc sur les résidus de
deuxième troisième extraction que que
l'on peut avoir qui sont pas les seules
sources mais qui sont effectivement des
sources importantes on a aussi d'autres
sources des d'éthanol côté vin ou autre
mais vous avez raison la betterave et
importante on a clairement même si j'ai
beaucoup révisé pour cette audition moi
j'ai cet élément là je l'ai parlé mais
on a des échanges fréquents au niveau de
la sous-direction avec le syndicat SNPA
et et les autres acteurs qu'on voit on
va dire de manière programmatique une
fois ou de parents pour faire un point
un peu global et en permanence donc
c'est vrai je pense c'est une des
questions je fais un centre de réponse
mais Vincent si vous avez des éléments
vous pour les indices à l'oral et on
vous les mettra en en écrit
donc oui et sur je vais pas dire qu'il y
a zéro un parc c'est sûr c'est quelque
chose qui qu'il faut qu'on regarde sur
notre sur notre filière éthanol sur la
question de la fin des des moteurs
thermiques et donc les impacts pour ces
biocarburants oui c'est une question
mais qui
n'est pas enfin mais aussi drastico ça
c'est d'abord c'est une idée pour les
véhicules légers de vente en 2035 donc
alors évidemment ça va pas être ça et en
2035 on s'arrête il va y avoir une pente
mais il y a d'abord un stock important
et puis il y a tout ce qui est le parc
routier où il a aussi la décarbonation
avec une partie des véhicules ne seront
plus à carburant liquide est-ce qu'ils
sont à biogaz à hydrogène électrique
mais il pourra en rester mais donc vous
aurez quand même des parcs qui restent
et vous aurez aussi tout le volet
maritime et fluvial qui peut être des
des consommateurs alors et certains que
c'est plus simple en simplifiant extrême
de reconvertir du diesel du bio diesel
vers des bateaux ou etc que de l'essence
que le de l'éthanol ou dieud 95
parce que globalement
le moteur à essence existe surtout en en
véhicule léger mais pense la partie
biosial
sans savoir ce que sera 2050 a
probablement une vision plus longue
d'utilisation assez facile à apporter de
la main si vous voulez moi j'ai en ayant
c'est en réaction socialement la
certitude que la CV est bonne etc pour
dire clairement on a des échanges
intenses avec le secteur fluvial qui me
disent écoutez nous il va falloir faire
des choses et on aimerait bien avoir du
biocarburant à la fin de à la fin du
match donc voilà enfin il y a c'est
évidemment pas énorme ici mais
aujourd'hui c'est 8% d'un gros paquet ça
peut devenir
50% de paquets plus petits voilà et qui
ça va donc il y a il y a une
transition
générale pour
socialement les alors les surfaces
occupées là je ne l'ai pas sous la
Manche on essaie de répondre aux
questionnaires mais je suis pas sûr que
ça on vous donnera les les éléments de
la France à Genève oui non mais non mais
les équipes les anges
on a
pour le coup c'est pas quelque chose que
que je connais par cœur
on va recevoir François Grimmer et on
aura sans doute la précision à ce
moment-là de toute façon si vous pouvez
nous la fournir entre temps c'est encore
mieux et on les verra on a et sachant
que certaines filières utilisent plus de
la surface
pour des cultures directes alors que
d'autres sont plutôt en résidus
certaines filières oui en déchets facile
betterave c'est voilà oui voilà mais
c'est plus
sur les ACV il y a des suivis il y a des
réglementations européennes et et il y a
des suivis et des preuves à apporter et
avec des exigences qui plusines et
récentes plus ça doit être un important
c'est plutôt et on a des on a des
chiffres on est ce sens on a justement
des des données assez précises sur la
décomposition on peut dire comparé un
carburant fossiles c'est pas le serveur
fossile sa production c'est c'est pas
très cher par contre c'est son émission
qui est cher et on a pour les
biocarglandiens et G2 des éléments que
vous retrouvez dans le questionnaire sur
pour fabriquer un litre qu'est-ce que
quelle est la part matière quelle est la
part process etc
je dirais pas je
donnerai pas dans l'angélisme mais avec
aussi tout ce qu'on a mis en place sur
l'interdiction d'un certain nombre de
produits et un système européen qui
s'est perfectionné et durci
c'est il y a une vraie durabilité et des
vrais réductions de d'émissions de gaz à
effet de serre des biocarburants
utilisés aujourd'hui c'est mieux suivi
et c'est plus important que il y a 10-15
ans c'est pas un jugement de valeur
c'est pas un cri de triomphe c'est pas
du tout je veux dire c'est et par
ailleurs nous y compris en liaison la
seule direction en liaison avec des
collègues étrangers et celle sur les
tout ça qu'on nous refile pas par des
certificats des cargaisons douteux etc
on y va je pense par ailleurs pareil le
monde économique est pas angélique mais
ceux qui sont dans ce domaine savent
qu'ils ont aussi à faire très attention
parce que un système aujourd'hui pour
être très vite déstabilisé par un
certain nombre de fraudes qui serait mis
en oeuvre sur des sujets qui sont pas
simples et qui peuvent donner alors
super ce que ce que cela dit c'est
effectivement si vous voulez produire de
la betterave pour la manger ou pour la
mettre en énergie c'est exactement la
même ou presque ce que j'ai dit c'est
que on va dire on est obligé de manger
et donc ce qu'on accepte même si c'est
de les limiter comme un train pour
produire de la plante c'est un peu de la
plante ou du bétail après voilà c'est
une base mais si on doit avoir des
volumes importants d'un train pas
toujours efficace il y a des façons
efficaces pour faire une plante qui
elle-même après en énergie n'est pas
extraordinaire en termes de rendement
c'est ça que je voulais dire
voilà j'ai juste dit ça c'est pour ça
qu'il y a les
non non c'est juste c'est pour ça qu'il
y a l'Analyse de Cycle de Vie c'est pour
ça aussi que parfois vous savez il y a
quand même certaines cultures
intermédiaires qui peuvent être
produites sans trop d'un an et qui ont
quand même un pouvoir méthanogène c'est
intéressant si un contrat vous êtes
obligé de leur mettre tellement
d'engrais pour que voilà il s'agit pas
non plus de planter uniquement le
miscanthus qui paraît-il est très
énergiving donne beaucoup d'énergie il
s'agit pas non plus de venir dans la
monoculture alors les bons sur sur les
les enfin les les facteurs limitants et
les comparaisons il y a un certain
nombre d'éléments dans le questionnaire
et on essaiera peut-être de les mettre
sous les formes que que vous évoluez oui
on a des visions aujourd'hui des des
prix du biocarburant de 1g de g de
l'hydrogène et même des carburants
synthétiques évidemment à terme de cinq
ans on peut voir
il y a des choses c'est pas le mandat le
plus carburant de première génération
son prix il va plus bouger enfin c'est
il va fluctuer en fonction de la matière
frérotte mais la technologie est à peu
près matu tu ressens un peu il y en a
d'autres qui sont très chers qui vont
encore un peu décroître
bon le les facteurs limitants vont être
quand même enfin globalement la surface
si on voulait faire vraiment du dédié
c'est un facteur limitant et aussi pour
ceux qui sont quand même très
consommateurs d'hydrogène ou
d'électricité dans le process
il faut il coûte plus cher mais ici si
on remonte en global la propension à
payer n'est pas le seul jugement
on a rien contre les avions mais sous
prétexte que les avions pourraient payer
très cher mais si vous fait tout
l'hydrogène de France et qu'il y en ait
plus à mettre dans dans l'industrie
lorsqu'elle pourrait pas payer on aurait
un problème
alors les capacités maximales c'est un
peu difficile à dire parce que ça va
dépendre de beaucoup de facteurs mais on
ce qu'on peut peut-être mettre dans dans
ce tableau c'est les fourchettes de
potentiels que l'on a vu dans nos
travaux actuels qui modélise
ça sera pas on voulait mettre sera pas
c'est ce qu'on commence à essayer de
faire dans la pour nourrir notre
stratégie nationale bas carbone et la
PPE
ces documents de travail que c'est un
mystère envoie une mission information
c'est pas forcément ça qui va un jour
dans 3 ou 6 mois être mis dans dans la
PPE par le gouvernement comment plus on
est sur de contrario enfin je prends un
autre exemple le si vous me demandez
quel est le potentiel de l'éolien en mer
c'est assez simple c'est assez monomania
c'est on voit les contraintes et tout
c'est déjà très compliqué quand on est
sur la biomasse comme en plus il se il
s'interfèrent les uns les autres ça sera
peut-être un peu des des fourchettes
mais on doit être capable pour moi c'est
facile de demander au service mais on
avait déjà des on a déjà centre
d'éléments dans le questionnaire on va
peut-être remouliner un peu les réponses
au questionnaire pour intégrer cette
demande là
je voulais souligner un très bonne idée
de Pierre Cuypers c'est vrai que si on
arrive à avoir ce petit tableau entre
guillemets de pilotage on aura un bon
élément de visibilité et de partage de
la stratégie avec ce qu'on peut entendre
c'est à dire des doutes aussi des
questionsnements des points de
rendez-vous par moment aussi mais c'est
vrai que on peut peut-être échanger
là-dessus sachant que ça peut être un
document de travail qui peut nous aider
nous-mêmes à réfléchir voilà mais en
tout cas merci de d'accepter de
réfléchir avec nous comme ça ça me
paraît une très bonne chose évidemment
en ce moment des forces incertitudes
mais pas pour les biomasses sur les prix
tous les prix nous étions depuis 15 ans
dans un monde d'inflation zéro où les
technologies s'amélioraient les prix de
tout baissait là les prix ont beaucoup
augmenté certains vecteurs énergétiques
plus que d'autres enfin vous intégrer
beaucoup de béton ou autre vos prix
augmentent mais va tout rebouge enfin le
solaire les prix du soleil ont monté
mais ils sont à nouveau en train de
baisser donc on a des
des incertitudes assez fortes en ce
moment déjà que c'était pas simple de
lire la boule de cristal en ce moment
les prix deviennent à un peu fugace vous
se verrez d'ailleurs enfin
les courbes de biocarburant sont assez
frappantes
essayons de réfléchir à ce qui pourrait
se passer demain si d'aventure on nous
disait il y a plus de moteur diesel
c'est bien une tentation aujourd'hui
politique et de dire supprime le diesel
alors je voudrais vous poser la question
sur que vous importez du pétrole brut et
que vous l'apportez dans une raffinerie
donc la raffinerie c'est une colonne à
distillée dans le bas de la colonne ce
qui est lourd et d'habitude et autres et
puis ce qui est le plus léger c'est
c'est les étais donc voilà ça veut dire
que pour produire uniquement de
l'essence ou des plus légers et terre
Esther etc qu'est-ce qui est qu'est-ce
que l'on fait du gasoil que de toute
façon on serait condamné à produire pour
avoir des essences
que deviendrait c'est gasoil
alors effectivement il y a des
le problème de court terme ça peut dire
votre question n'existe pas le problème
de court terme qu'on a toujours eu en
France depuis 20 ans c'est qu'on
consomme plus de gazole que la
production naturelle d'une raffinerie
normale on est plutôt obligé de faire
des des acrobaties alors d'une part en
importation on est alors même qu'on a
fermé pas mal de raffinerie en France on
est autosuffisant en essence mais on
importe 40% de notre diesel donc notre
affinage parce que oui pour le moment
mais on a quand même une certaine mare
et même le raffinage encore récemment à
investi pour augmenter son taux de
conversion pour pour avoir plus de
diesel c'est une question
globale il y a pas que les diesels qui
ont consommé moins dans les enfin les
diesel est assimilé parce que le fioul
et le gazole n'ont pas tout ça c'est un
peu la même chose mais vous avez aussi
les Fieux lourds qui progressivement et
pas qu'en Europe enfin vont disparaître
de la production électrique puis enfin
pratiquement on a encore quelle turbine
mais c'est un pauvre c'est au léger et
dans et dans le monde de la navigation
on va il y aura plus de flots on va
aller vers aussi le carillon durable
donc c'est les
ces carburants vont devoir être enfin
retransformer soit en mélange avec avec
du bio diesel ou autre pour justement
les bateaux les ou les usages bon je
rappelle quand même que enfin pour
l'instant même s'il y a des questions
entre autres sur l'impact y compris des
dizaines récents en termes de pollution
de l'air aucune réglementation y compris
les zones à faible émission
contrairement à ce qui a pu dire aucune
interdit les diesels récents donc c'est
un sujet de et on voit et par ailleurs
au-delà enfin au-delà de l'impact sur
les raffineries on voit bien le problème
que serait d'interdire les diesels les
plus récents dans dans les villes donc
c'est une vraie une vraie question de
comment le raffinage à un moment à terme
il fera du carburant de synthèse et du
biocarburant avancé aujourd'hui fait
autre chose comment il évolue et sachant
que dans l'actualité vous l'avez bien vu
en septembre en octobre 2022 une autre
question c'était par ailleurs fallait
amener de l'essence et du diesel au pont
mais effectivement
l'investissement du raffinage va se
porter de plus en plus vers des
biocarburants durables des mélanges et
arrêter la fin et moins de course à la
dieselisation puisque effectivement
cette surconsommation de diesel va avoir
tendance à diminuer puisque les ventes
se sont rééquilibrées pour l'essence on
a encore un peu de marge pour pour voir
ça
merci y a-t-il
une question Béatrice
monsieur le rapporteur merci monsieur le
Président merci Monsieur le Directeur
général se différente réponse que c'est
une matière qui est complexe qui est
vaste et avec beaucoup d'enjeux deux
éléments peut-être d'actualité sur la
définition de l'hydrogène au niveau
européen
on entend des des
cocorico que qu'on partage on en est
satisfait le président a rappelé tout à
l'heure que y compris au Sénat on avait
plusieurs fois interrogé la mini sur
l'état d'avancée des discussions voilà
ce que vous pouvez nous en dire plus
est-ce que en quoi cette définition vous
paraît satisfaisante qu'est-ce qu'elle
règle comme comme problème puis
deuxièmement vous avez fait l'usure
vous-même ce matin le gouvernement reste
elle est un groupe de travail
sur les carburants synthétiques durable
pour l'aéronautique alors je suis
peut-être pas homo prêt mais en gros
c'est l'idée
je pense qu'on peut s'en réjouir et voir
que au moment où après quelques semaines
d'annonce de la Constitution cette
mission le gouvernement monte un groupe
de travail il avait sans doute fait des
choses on a vu les débats je me souviens
Stéphane Davis je crois était là avec
Monsieur Lescure en séance au moment du
PLF mais bon voilà qu'est-ce que ça
change ce groupe de travail pour vous en
perte de méthode en termes d'efficacité
et puis notamment il y avait des
appels à projets sur les justement les
l'hydrogène pour les Renault nautiques
il y a eu des appels d'offres sur les
biocarburants aéronautiques semble-t-il
et sur l'hydrogène aussi il y avait
notamment des appels d'offres avec des
pieds que européen où est-ce qu'on en
est de tout cela
je vais prendre la deuxième question je
ferai et puis je ferai un bout de
réponse de la première et Christophe
cassiotis qu'on
complétera sur les détails sur les
tellement l'édition européenne sur les
définitions de l'hydrogène et ce qui
reste à franchir alors effectivement
vous souvenez en fait qu'on avait adopté
en 2020 déjà une première feuille de
route sur les les biocarbures durables
dont en particulier pour l'aviation ça a
donné lieu au premier appel à projet
enfin appel la MAIF son intérêt et
projet et quatre premières quatre
premiers projets sélectionnés bon là
l'idée c'est
[Musique]
à la fois sans être une révolution ça
rend une confirmation de la priorité
politique et des prochaines actions ce
groupe installé par les trois ministres
d'abord il veut dire finalement que
nouveau
on donne le signal c'est que l'on
poursuit je crois que c'est un signal
qui est important en tant que tel et là
c'est ça a été aussi l'identification
d'un certain nombre de pistes dont une
concertation à lancer et à finir dans
quatre mois sur comment on fait et
comment on soutient on va dire
clairement comment on soutient les
nouvelles usines de production de
carburant durable avec par ailleurs le
train qui doit convenir plutôt cette
fois sur la recherche aéronautique les
les futurs pistes des des prochains
projets
etc plutôt la seule fois sur le volet
avion moteur donc c'est
c'est le on va dire ça le signal et
d'une deuxième phase finalement sur ah
pour les avions ça fait longtemps mais
là c'est celle d'une deuxième phase sur
les biocarburants ou sur les les avions
étant donné l'autre de des travaux et
d'aller vers l'industrialisation
mais par ailleurs c'est effectivement
aussi de dire le retour d'expérience des
des premiers projets et aussi
probablement ce qui est nouveau
c'est en même temps enfin c'est pas
nouveau c'est pas une surprise mais
c'est une confirmation c'est vraiment le
fait que le monde de l'aviation souhaite
maintenant il va y avoir aussi les
obligations européennes mais il y a
aussi les Américains qui eux ils vont
faire 10% sur des carburants un peu
moins durables que les nôtres donc
jamais confondre enfin tout comparer
comme ça de manière simpliste mais c'est
vraiment ce souhait d'accélérer aussi
qui a été inclus enfin qui serait
exprimer là après venir on est dans un
travail tout en renouvelé va tester les
propositions d'écouter ces acteurs ont à
faire à dire de lancer éventuellement de
nouveaux soutiens ou de lever des freins
s'il y avait des freins réglementaires
de certification des carburants des
moteurs etc sur les débats européens
entre ce sur l'hydrogène comme l'avait
dit là on a entre autres un acte délégué
clarifie et aussi officialisent comment
un hydrogène peut être renouvelable mais
aussi comment
bas carbone les débats qui restent à
avoir comme
tous les outils donnent plus de
subsidiarité sur les objectifs
obligatoires et ou indicatifs il y a des
obligatoires pour l'instant enfin ce
sont des projets entre le Règlement sur
les carburants pour maritime ou aviation
ou la directive red3 dans certains cas
il y a des objectifs indicatifs et
d'autres qui seront contraignants mais
notre souhait c'est que au-delà d'une
définition
l'ivresse incontestable et qui perdra
dire oui ça c'est de la variable en soit
ça de la valeur dire qu'un hydrogène
fait à partir moyennant des conditions
très strictes et bas carbone ça a de la
valeur parce que au-delà des obligations
etc il y a les entreprises vont dire
avec ça je vais pouvoir faire des bilans
carbone qui sont qui mettent moins etc
ça sera vrai ça sera validé mais par
ailleurs les objectifs enfin si
vous pouvez pas avoir je vais prendre
raison vous pouvez pas dire
contradictoires de dire que mettons il
faudrait 7% de biody de diesel dont 6
serait à partir de telles molécules et
3% à partir de l'autre ça ne colle pas
donc si l'objectif est trop porté sur le
renouvelable on va avoir du mal à
l'atteindre on va faire même des
acrobaties mais et donc il reste un
certain nombre d'États à franchir une
rotation Christophe suit ça oui alors
sur les sujets européens en fait on
discute à plusieurs niveaux on discute
de la mise en oeuvre du paquet fit for
fifty-five et là le sujet c'est des
textes qui sont au niveau des directives
on a la directive renouvelable on a
d'autres d'autres paquets comme le
paquet gaz qui va définir le futur
marché d'hydrogène et la manière dont
cette hydrogène va être transportée et
on a des objectifs plus sectoriels comme
dans review maritime ou récu l'aviation
donc ça c'est des discussions en cours
ce qui a été présenté ce week-end enfin
ce weekend et publié en début de semaine
c'est des actes délégués c'est des actes
délégués qui viennent décliner la
précédente directive Red et qui viennent
définir l'hydrogène renouvelable le
sujet qu'on avait donc pour définir
l'hydrogène renouvelable il est produit
à partir d'électricité la question qu'on
peut se poser c'est je suis un
producteur d'hydrogène est-ce que je
peux utiliser de l'électricité qui est
produit en France ou ailleurs en Europe
et est-ce que je peux compter mon
hydrogène renouvelable si j'ai acheté
l'électricité renouvelable il y a un
mois et pas au moment où je produis et
donc les actes délégués ils viennent
préciser un certain nombre de règles et
notamment ils vont imposer une
corrélation temporaire et géographique à
partir d'une certaine date pour tous les
pays européens
ils vont aussi imposer des méthodologies
de calcul donc la manière dont on va
faire les analyses de cycle de vie et ce
que faisait les versions précédentes
c'est qu'ils imposaient ce qu'on
appelait l'additionnalité l'idée au
niveau européen c'est d'éviter que la
production d'hydrogène Vienne réduire le
rythme de décarbonation électrique dans
des pays qui ont un mix fossile existant
de l'électricité existant dans les pays
qui ont un mix fossile important qui se
mettent à produire beaucoup
d'électricité d'hydrogène renouvelable
et bien ils vont devoir continuer à
maintenir leur parc existant de de
production fossiles et donc c'est pour
ça que l'Europe
voulait fixer des règles d'additionalité
qui nous permettaient pas d'utiliser
l'électricité renouvelable historique et
c'est une situation qui s'applique très
mal à la France mais aussi à d'autres
pays comme la Suède qui ont une part
importante de renouvelables et de bas
carbone et donc ce qui a été fixé dans
les textes européens c'est qu'on pourra
utiliser l'électricité renouvelable
qu'on a déjà
sans avoir besoin de faire de
l'additionnalité donc c'est pas c'est
pas une grande victoire en soi mais ça
ça c'est le reflet de la réalité
physique de notre mix et on est content
d'avoir quand même réussi à convaincre
nos partenaires du fait que c'était que
c'était pertinent quoi sur les objectifs
d'hydrogène qui sont dans la directive
renouvelable donc il y a un objectif
global de renouvelable dans l'énergie et
après il y a des objectifs pour
l'hydrogène qui peuvent être secteur par
secteur pour l'industrie pour les
transports l'objectif pour l'industrie
il est très élevé il est d'environ au
stade des discussions il est à plus de
40% en 2030 et il est au-delà de 60% en
2035 la difficulté qu'on a c'est que cet
objectif il est calculé sur la totalité
de l'hydrogène produit ça veut dire que
bon si on produit l'hydrogène
renouvelable on va substituer
l'hydrogène fossile et ça ça nous va
bien dans nos stratégies mais telle que
l'objectif est formulé toute molécules
d'hydrogène bas carbone produite à
partir dans notre mix va réduire le
l'objectif qu'on va atteindre et ça
c'est quand même une difficulté parce
que nous on veut c'est l'objectif c'est
de décarboner grâce à cette production
d'hydrogène et donc c'est pour ça qu'on
a des discussions avec nos partenaires
européens qui sont pas tous convaincus
de la pertinence de notre proposition
pour pour bien cibler
l'utilisation des renouvelables pour des
carboner sans que 60 en concurrence avec
l'hydrogène produit à partir de notre
mix électrique pour atteindre l'objectif
de Run pour atteindre l'objectif de
renouvelable faudrait presque
s'interdire de produire de l'hydrogène
des carbonée finalement c'est c'est et
ça c'est un peu ces contre intuitif il
faut qu'on arrive à pousser les deux
enfin dans un endroit où il y a pas
d'autre électricité des carbonées que le
renouvelable ça pose pas problème c'est
nous ça serait finalement limitant
merci pas d'autres questions mes
collègues
moi j'en avais une toute petite sur
l'électricité
sur la possibilité de ce qu'on appelle
l'autoroute électrique ou les
pour les camions oui alors c'est un
c'est des projets effectivement qui ont
été pas mal travaillés dans l'Europe du
Nord entre autres par Scania et avec une
des versions allemandes il y a deux
versions il y a la version ça ressemble
à des trains avec des pantographes et il
y a aussi il y a aussi la version sur la
chaussée
je vous avoue que là je saurais pas vous
dire si ça avance beaucoup il y en a ou
deux il y a pas mal de projets
oui il y a des tests là on va faire si
vous voulez on peut mettre un petit code
ici dans les faire le point avec nos
équipes savoir si j'ai l'impression
quand même mes amis me parlent plutôt
carrément d'électrification directe avec
camion à batterie de plus en plus
performant plutôt que ces modèles là qui
nécessite des grosses infra quoi il faut
changer la route mais
on vous fait le point merci beaucoup pas
d'autres questions écoutez Monsieur le
Directeur Général merci pour votre
introduction je pense que nous avons
trouvé très pédagogique et très clair et
merci à votre équipe et à vous-même pour
la qualité de vos réponses